did you see that Viral Tick Tock where
the the I think as a woman she's like
why do I have to work full time just to
live
and it's it's like seriously that's
their attitude I'm like entropy I guess
oxidization your body falls apart unless
you do it's like that's because office
job work like normal Corporate America
work is kind of soul-sucking so I get
why she said it I gotta be honest if you
know I was about to enter the gates of
eternity and they said there's one where
you're sitting in an office all day and
one where you have to hunt and forage
for survival I'd go with the hunting and
foreign
food right what I'm saying is like if I
had to choose a life between
farming how about that and office work I
choose farming